>> Tucker: THE CULTURAL
REVOLUTION NOW IN PROGRESS IS
MAKING A DANGEROUS TURN,
ACTUALLY BEEN HERE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME, WATCHING ELECTED
LEADERS SAY YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THEIR SYSTEM
IF YOU ARE THE WRONG COLOR.
DURING A RECENT ARGUMENT ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN OF LOUISIANA ARGUED
THAT SOME PEOPLE JUST SHOULDN’T
BE IN THE DEBATE BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE WRONG SKIN COLOR OR
THEIR CHILDREN ARE.
RICHMOND’S CLAIM STARTED OFF
WITH A FIGHT WITH FLORIDA
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ.
>> YOU ALL ARE WHITE MALES.
YOU NEVER LIVED IN MY SHOES AND
YOU DO NOT KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE
TO BE AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN MALE.
>> ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT
YOU’RE CERTAIN THAT NONE OF US
HAVE NONWHITE CHILDREN?
BECAUSE HE REFLECTED ON YOUR
BLACK SON, THAT NONE OF US COULD
UNDERSTAND.
>> I AM NOT ABOUT TO GET
SIDETRACKED ABOUT THE COLOR OF
OUR CHILDREN.
I RECLAIM MY TIME.
IS NOT ABOUT THE COLOR OF YOUR
KIDS.
IT IS ABOUT BLACK MALES, BLACK
PEOPLE IN THE STREETS THAT ARE
GETTING KILLED AND IF ONE OF
THEM HAPPENS TO BE YOUR KID, I’M
CONCERNED ABOUT HIM TOO AND
CLEARLY I’M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
HIM THEN YOU ARE.
SO LET’S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU THINK I’M THINK YOU ARE M
CONCERNED ABOUT MY FAMILY.
YOU SHOULD TAKE THOSE WORDS DOWN
DOWN.
>> THE GENTLEMAN WILL SUSPEND.
IT BELONGS TO THE GENTLEMAN FROM
LOUISIANA.
>> WAS THAT A NERVE?
>> THE GENTLEMAN FROM LOUISIANA.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU ATTACK
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
RACE AND THEIR CHILDREN, YOU GET
EXCHANGES LIKE THAT.
CEDRIC RICHMOND WILL NEVER BE
DISCIPLINED FOR IT.
AFTERWARD, MATT GAETZ ISSUED THE
STATEMENT ON TWITTER.
"FOR ALL THOSE WONDERING, MY SON
CAME FROM CUBA LEGALLY AND LIVES
WITH ME IN FLORIDA."
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
CEDRIC RICHMOND WHO WENT TO
TULANE LAW SCHOOL AND BRAGS
ABOUT HIS LAW DEGREE WAS TELLING
YOU THAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CONVERSATION
BECAUSE OF YOUR SKIN COLOR?
>> I BELIEVE EVERYONE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IF THEY ARE
BLACK, WHITE, OR OTHERWISE AND
IT IS CERTAINLY OFFENSIVE TO
HAVE SOMEONE TELL YOU THAT YOU
DON’T KNOW WHAT A CERTAIN
EXPERIENCE IS LIKE WHEN THEY
KNOW NOTHING ABOUT YOU.
NESTOR IS THE LIGHT OF MY LIFE.
I COULDN’T IMAGINE LOVING HIM
ANYMORE IF HE WAS MY OWN FLESH
AND BLOOD.
I’VE RAISED HIM FOR THE LAST SIX
YEARS, AND HE IS THE MOST
REMARKABLE YOUNG MAN.
I AM PROUD OF HIM, AND I AM
HONESTLY EMBARRASSED OF THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS THAT WE
HAVE RESORTED TO CRITICIZING
EACH OTHER BASED ON OUR RACE AND
THE RACE OF OUR CHILDREN AND I
WISH THAT WE COULD BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE GOING FORWARD.
>> Tucker: DID ANY REPUBLICANS
ON YOUR SIDE OF THE AISLE STAND
UP AND MAKE THAT POINT?
IT SEEMS LIKE A PRETTY BASIC
THRESHOLD THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO ATTACK PEOPLE FOR THINGS THEY
CAN’T CONTROL.
DID ANYONE ELSE JOINING YOUR
DEFENSE?
>> THERE WERE SOME REPUBLICANS
WHO POINTED OUT THAT WE
SHOULDN’T BE TREATING ANYBODY
DIFFERENTLY AS A CONSEQUENCE OF
THEIR RACE.
JUST GOT TO SAY, HE HAS A
REMARKABLE YOUNG MAN.
I AM PROUD OF HIM, AND I HAVE
RAISED HIM TO BELIEVE THAT IN
OUR FAMILY, WE TREAT EVERYONE
EQUALLY.
DOESN’T MATTER WHAT THEIR
BACKGROUND IS, WE TREAT EVERY
AMERICAN WITH RESPECT.
>> Tucker: DOES HE LEARN THAT
AT SCHOOL AS WELL?
AND USING THE CULTURE IN WHICH
HE IS GOING UP REINFORCES THAT?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
CEDRIC RICHMOND’S ATTACKS?
DID YOU SEE ALL OF THIS?
>> I DID NOT SEE IT BECAUSE I
WAS SLEEPING FROM WORK THE NIGHT
BEFORE, BUT ONCE I WOKE UP, I
WOKE UP TO SEEING ALL THESE
TWEETS AND I WAS LIKE WHAT IS
GOING ON?
AND GIVE ME A CALL TELLING ME
ABOUT IT AND THEN I SAW IT, AND
I THINK IT’S UNFAIR TO TELL
SOMEONE THAT THEY DON’T
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THEY DON’T
HAVE -- BECAUSE OF THEIR RACIAL
COLOR.
WHILE HE IS FIGHTING FOR
EQUALITY BUT IF YOU TELL SOMEONE
DID NOT GET INVOLVED, DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE OF THE COLOR,
YOU ARE BEING A HYPOCRITE THERE.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS
VERY NICELY PUT.
CONGRESSMAN GAETZ, SAYING THIS
OUT LOUD SEEMS LIKE THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT IN NORMAL TIMES, YOU
WOULD BE CENSURED FOR.
>> I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT IT’S
ACCEPTABLE IN THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS FOR SOMEONE TO TELL
SOMEONE ELSE THAT THEY ARE
FIGHTING FOR THEIR CHILDREN MORE
THAN THEY ARE.
YOU HAVE A SON.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF SOMEONE
SAID TO YOU THAT THEY WERE
FIGHTING FOR YOUR OWN FAMILY
MORE THAN YOU WERE?
THAT’S WHY I GOT VERY UPSET, BUT
FOR THE SAKE OF NESTOR AND MY
STORY, WE ARE VERY PROUD FAMILY
AND LOVE EACH OTHER VERY MUCH
AND HE’S ON HIS WAY OFF TO
COLLEGE IN THE FALL AND I
COULDN’T BE HAPPIER AND PROUDER
OF THE YOUNG MAN HE’S BECOME AND
THE FACT THAT HE IS EMBRACING
THESE AMERICAN VALUES THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD BE TREATED
FAIRLY AND EQUALLY.
>> Tucker: THAT’S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
I TELL MY KIDS ARE NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHO YOUR
RELATIVES ARE, YOU ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT YOU DO WHEN